[Music]
okay we're playing a 2300 so let's go e4
this time
and he plays the modern now we already
have faced the modern
a lot of times and my favorite system of
development is to put this bishop on e3
the point being
we want to keep our center nicely
protected
so a6 prepares b5 but there's a
complicated
so a4 here is possible um
there's basically several ways of
playing this we could play a4 and stop
b5
but we're actually going to allow it and
b5 is annoying
but not as annoying as it may appear now
we're going to go we're gonna go h4
we're gonna start attacking the king
side
okay now what is the drawback of the
move h5
like he stops us from going h5 ourselves
what is the drawback of this move
uh who can explain that to me now first
of all we need to play f3 to support
this pawn the drawback is that it
weakens g5
and that's exactly what we're going to
do here we're going to go knight h3 and
knight g5
sinking our knight into the weak square
that he's just created
okay now we need to complete our
development
but we need to do it in a very very
careful way so we're going to actually
castle first we're going to castle along
we're going to see
what how he sort of develops his pieces
that's going to help us understand
where we need to put our bishop so
what's what's a good follow-up to
castling
that i've played a couple times this
king on c1 could be improved
um what am i referring to specifically
so move like king b1
and i'll talk about this a little after
the game is a very good follow-up to
castling long
because the king is just safer there
it's away from the c file
all of this stuff now what black is
preparing here is the move c5
so if we put our bishop on d3
then we obstruct our own control of the
file and we help him play c5
and that's not something i necessarily
want to do
but there is a really cool idea that we
could try to apply so what should we do
here instead joe thank you for the sub
now this knight on c3
this knight can be improved and this is
a typical idea in these positions where
can we lead this knight
so we can go to e2 we can try to go to
f4 that has its own dangers okay so he
does go c5
he sort of goes c5 automatically and we
can go knight f4 that's
very very thematic and typical maneuver
um and uh you should remember it
basically
so he can play cd and e5 but i
anticipated that i don't think that
actually works
we'll see though so there's there's a
lot of things to talk about in these
positions but
okay so the reason e5 and i actually
blundered so bishop c3 was my idea
because he can't take
but what i blundered was the move b4 now
the good thing is because i've played
this in the way that i have we can
actually sacrifice the piece
and i think we have very legitimate
compensation for the piece
let's see if he finds b4 well knight d5
he'll just take on d5 and then he'll
take the bishop let's see if he finds b4
he doesn't okay so what should we do now
we don't actually have to move this
knight but but we will
uh because the d5 square is extremely
weak so we're going to occupy it with
our knight and then we're going to
reoccupy it with our queen
um this opening is is absolutely legit
so ooh he goes queen d7 okay
so he leaves the knight here now how
should we go about playing this position
what we should do we should try to find
if we can
infiltrate what are the weak avenues in
his position one thing i'm seeing right
i'm seeing that there's this diagonal so
we can put our bishop here the bishop
has done its job on c3 now it was just
biting on granite
now we're going to improve the position
of our bishop we're going to get the
rook out of the picture
now we have two possibilities we can
give a check on c7
but i think even better perhaps is to go
knight b6 and then capture the pawn on
t6
um but the problem with that
is that we trade queens and i feel like
we could get more out of this position
if that makes sense
but you know but it's fine upon is upon
let's not
let's not overthink it i'm just gonna
take it yes we still have all the
superiorities that we had previously we
have our pieces on dominant positions
you can see how passive he is
okay he attacks the rook we need to move
it back and
we can circle back to d5 with our knight
we also need to develop
the bishops we need to connect the rooks
he's not actually threatening really to
take at all
so we have several ways of playing this
we can go bishop e2
let's complete our development first now
this pawn is very weak i'm noticing this
pawn i'm saying aha this pawn is weak
how can we attack the spawn again it's
all about flexibility there's a certain
piece
that has already done its job on the
square that it that it is on
right now how can we attack this pawn
find the move
bishop c3 repositioning the bishop
attacking the pawn if he goes knight d7
and defends there is a tactic
the tactic is to notice that the king is
overloaded simple overloading tactic
what is the tactic
that has some yeah i'm going a little
bit a little bit faster because this
guy's really strong and i don't want to
lose on time
and he simply resigns so he just got
disappointed i mean actually the funny
thing is
if he goes king e6 and he tries to chase
the rook away from d7
what would white do here a lot to unpack
in this game and i will what would we do
here
who can find a little tactic
yeah so not immediately a lot of people
are thinking this
that's the right thought because this is
the idea but remember that you can take
the rook and the rooks defend each other
so white's going to be down a piece
but that's the right idea we need to
play this first then we take on e5
we're gonna win the exchange back and
we're gonna be up three pawns and at
this level
when you're three pawns down there's
absolutely no chance
i mean that's just an overwhelming
advantage that was a very nice game
okay so let's talk about what happened
there's a lot a lot to discuss here
don't panic we will i will guide you
through everything that i did
that's the fun part about analyzing
afterward
um and just be prepared we're going to
take a while on these games because i
want to squeeze all the instructive
content out of it it's not about playing
the maximum amount of games i really
want you guys to
to fully appreciate the logic and stuff
so the modern we've faced before several
times i'm not going to talk about the
modern
general i mean it's it's a hyper
literally called the modern
and it's similar to the perk now one of
the key differences between the perk and
the modern
as you guys probably know the perk is
when you go d6
then knight f6 and then g6 so if you
just
visually compare the knight is not on f6
yet
and so black has all of these setups
that involve delaying
the move knight f6 letting the bishop
have this influence over the diagonal
without blocking that's why a6
is the sort of more modern continuation
this is a theory this is not senseless
this is the theory the main line
now why didn't i play a4 the logic
behind this guys is actually very simple
which side am i probably going to castle
on given that i've expressed my desire
to castle to
attack on the king side which which side
is
yeah so we're probably in the castle can
you guys appreciate that a move like a4
in in conjunction with castleing long
could lead to
big problems for example um if if he
develops and i develop
and let's just say he goes knight b7 and
castles long what move now becomes
possible for black very nasty little
move
that uses this pawn as a hook to open up
a file
bingo so b5 is super nasty if you just
myopically well if you take with a
knight you get checkmated that's how
quickly this could backfire
but even if you take with a bishop i
think everybody can appreciate how nasty
it is that now black has this going and
he opens up another file and and you
know all of this can collapse super
quickly so
the move a4 is a big weakness in
conjunction with castling along this
would basically restrict me
to castling short which is fine that's
another setup
but in this game i want it to cast along
so we allow this move
now we go h4 h5 and f3 now
the benefits of castling long is that it
allows you to castle short
sorry it allows you to attack on the
other side of the board
um without worrying about king safety if
you if you were to castle short and then
attack on that side
you would have to be incredibly cautious
about pushing your pawns out you
wouldn't be able to do that if that
makes sense and black basically
has to castle this side i mean he's gone
a6 b5 so
you know black castle and queen's height
here would be unthinkable
yeah castling castling to c1 and then to
g1
tranquil c i'll talk about that that's a
fantastic question now the idea of the
move f3 is to
is to take the sting out of the move
bishop b7 if we didn't do this
if we just developed normally then the
very nasty move would be b4
and this pawn becomes very weak so f3 is
to ensure
that the bishop isn't as good on b7 so
knight d7
now we got our knight to g5 that's the
weak square created by the move h5
and um he plays z6 which is
sort of a very typical typical way of
developing he gets his knight to e7
knight f6 is also possible but the
problem here is there's e5 ideas that
white has in the future
this knight could get caught in the
crossfire so this is totally normal
now we castle we go queenie sub so
a great question was asked by tranquil c
what is the difference between a piece
biting on granite and having good
potential energy well that involves
forecasting the future that's part of
like the kind of logic that i'm trying
to get you guys to have
the bishop for example on b7 is biting
on granite that's not a very good bishop
why doesn't the bishop have potential
energy because even if this diagonal
were to open
even if he were to get the spawn out of
e4 there would be this pawn chain that
the bishop would be leaning against and
also
nothing particularly important is
happening on this diagonal like
even if the bishop were completely open
it's not like it would be participating
directly and attacking my king
so you want to think about like what is
likely to happen in the future
how likely is it to happen and even if
it does happen like how much does
the piece that gets opened benefit and
the bishop on b7 is just kind of out of
the game permanently
uh why didn't they put the bishop on g5
instead of the knight that's a good
question because the bishop is on e3 it
has an important job
it's guarding this the d4 square so if i
were to put the vision on g5 he could
strike with c5 this pawn would be
softened up
and i'd have to react negatively to this
i'd have to take and that lets his
knight into the game
and then the knight wouldn't have any
square to go
okay so now king b1
improving the king rook d8 why didn't i
develop my bishop so as i explained
during the game
this loosens the contact between my
queen and the pawn it weakens the pawn
this makes c5 a lot stronger now he's
threatening c takes d4
and i really don't want to take on c5
here because
he takes um d takes c5 he opens up the
file
these pawns can just roll me out of the
gym here
why don't i play d5 because on a on a
logical level it opens up his bishop
right now his bishop is super strong and
he can combine the bishop with these
pawns and start a very very nasty attack
on the queen side c4 and then b4 and
you guys should be able to just see how
nasty this could become this is a nasty
little attack
and the basic reaction that i want to
have to c5
is to ignore it um no this is fine this
is the correct way to play it it's just
that this line has drawbacks you know as
i've explained
not in every position is all of your
pieces are all of your pieces going to
be amazing
this he's played this i think by and
large correctly i think his main mistake
is about to happen so he takes e5 and
now bishop c3 this is what i had
calculated
obviously if he takes tonight i play
bishop takes g7
and his rook is actually trapped even if
it wasn't this would be a disaster
but the rook is actually trapped all
three squares are covered
so i'm not sure resurrect what you're
asking like um
you know i don't think he could have
played d take c3 what if he plays b4 so
that was his correct move
i actually missed this the idea of b4 is
to distract the bishop this is a
distraction
or a decoy sacrifice you're getting the
bishop off of the long diagonal
if my pawn was on b3 i would go bishop
b2 but i can't do that
so i have to take and what happens here
bishop takes b4 he takes my knight so he
wins a piece
but what does white do here to get
maximal compensation for the piece like
what is the best follow-up move
and could somebody explain to me like on
a logical level
why is this not winning for black like
what does what's compensation consist of
i'm going to take a couple bites sorry
yeah so white's compensation is number
one two pawns for the piece and number
two the initiative what does that mean
now at this level part of the reason
that the game can be hard to follow
is because there's a lot of elements to
the position right
you might look at this and say well
black's up a piece he's winning well
he's not white's got two puns
white's got a huge initiative which
manifests itself in the fact that black
is not developed
well this this there is checkmate so
what we need to do here in order to
conduct the initiative well is to find
ways to defend against the threats with
tempo
tempo is incredibly important so mr
alamo move like bishop a3 is not bad
but that's actually not the best move
what we need to look for can we defend
against me
while also posing a threat to our
opponent in the move here is queen b4 e5
is interesting
but i'm not sure you have anything after
knight takes e5 this gets a little too
tactical
the bishop gets caught on the crossfire
i don't think this works
so queen b4 is the best vote this should
make sense to everybody we are attacking
the bishop and we're defending against
mate
like i've said many times you want to
leave the queen for the most important
tasks
this is an important task if the bishop
moves
how can we now develop a temple we can
take the pawn that's fine but i don't
think that's the best we can do how can
we develop with tempo
bishop c4 is correct now this is not
winning immediately black can defend
with knight h6
but look how bad black's position is
he's completely frozen he can't castle
and already a move like e5 has to be
considered just blasting everything open
and i think checkmate will follow
checking with a computer here it's plus
seven i take c5 okay g1
and look at how amazing white's position
is so according to the computer this is
already better for white this is the
correct idea
and i'm going to check my accuracy here
so bishop c3 white is much better
b4 is still his best move and after
bishop takes before ef and bishop d6
black has an insane resource that
actually complicates the game can
somebody actually take a stab at what
this is
because any human would automatically
move their queen but
black has another idea and the idea
stems from noticing that there is a pin
or an x-ray that the rook exerts on the
queen so we can actually move the knight
away
the idea is if we take the queen black
takes the queen
white takes the rook black takes the
bishop if you count up the material
black has two pieces for a rook
and um i think two pawns which is slight
slight material advantage for white but
you've gotten the queens off the board
blackened castle
so if i were white i would not actually
take the queen i would play queen d4 or
something like that just keeping the
tension
and maybe pressuring the knight um so
this is a very nice resource black is
still worse
but in the game he goes knight c5 allows
us to access the d5 square and then he
doesn't take the knife for some reason
let me again charge my headphones so
basically he he should have taken the
knight
and the secondary perk of this
is i think that that black can go knight
f6 now and he can develop a tempo
black is worse why is black horse who
can explain to me
verbally um what
factors compose white's advantage here
if you look if you were to look at this
position
how do i know that white's better who
can lay these out for me
this is actually really important to be
able to make the right observations like
this in my opinion
it also gives me a chance to eat
so control the center yep you guys are
all correct
a pardon the speech but one very
important thing that i have not
introduced yet
i'm going to unlock a concept that i
have not talked about at all in the
speed run
i have waited specifically until
approximately 22 50.
that is the notion of static versus
dynamic factors
you're like oh
static versus dynamic factors um
is my mic like um is the sound quality
bad i mean i think i improved the
settings but i did already get a better
mic and i will be installing it
shortly it should sound fine yeah
so static versus dynamic factors
now as the words imply a static factor
is something
that is relatively permanent it's a part
of the position that
it's not that it will forever be the
case but it's very very hard to get rid
of
thanks clyde welcome so for example one
of the static factors in the black's
position is the backward one
static just means immovable or something
like something that's
unlikely to be gone in the next couple
of moves now yes one could make the case
that black can go d5 but that's kind of
unlikely
that's kind of unlikely because that's
going to drop the e pawn so the backward
pawn
that's probably gonna remain for a long
time another thing that's a static
factor
the bishop notice black's bishop it is
literally
completely devoid of potential energy
it's biting on granite my favorite term
can you guys really see a way that this
bishop gets better not really right i
mean you can go to h6
it can even take the knight but even
that contains its own problems the
bishop is
kind of permanently bad here what's a
dynamic factor a dynamic factor is the
fact that white is castled and black is
not
because either black is going to castle
the next couple of moves or he's not
it's it's one thing or the other thing
and it's very likely that he will castle
thank you oprah so what is the way that
so what you need to do when you're
evaluating a position is you need to
categorize in some way
the static and dynamic factors and you
need to ask yourself first and foremost
if you can exploit the dynamic factors
first
because they tend to evaporate like you
don't need to worry yet about
attacking d6 with all of your might
because that pawn is likely to remain
weak for a long time and so queen c6
check
would be the best way to exploit the
dynamic factor which is the fact that
black is not castled yet and if black
plays queen d7
then it's fine to go into an endgame and
because the d6 pawn is a dynamic
sorry as a static weakness who can
propose for me a
long-term plan to attack this phone what
sequence of moves would allow white now
to pile up on this d6 pawn and this
doesn't have to be
that fast i mean rook takes c6 here
doesn't work unfortunately
uh because of the background that's
another dynamic factor
yeah you double rook so one thing you
could do that's really five head is to
go g3
g3 would get the bishop to h3
this would prevent black from doubling
rooks making it harder for him to defend
the pawn d5 would drop this one
and so rook d1 follows and the bishop
could come to b4 if the knight moves
black is going to be in very big trouble
here okay
so that's a way of looking at the
position i'll apply that a little bit
more in subsequent games
i know that it might not seem all that
important to you guys right now but i
just wanted to introduce this concept
slowly
um so anyways that's why black would be
worse here but he doesn't do that
and here we do exploit the dynamic
factors
which is the fact that black is not
castled so his king is weak so we can
basically play
near his king pawn on d6 is incredibly
weak we win the pawn we get into an end
game
and um this is like incredibly hard to
defend for black i mean
not only is he down a pawn whoa not only
is he down the pawn but tommy [ __ ]
shall be gifting 10 subs in the meeting
the best troll in the world damn girl
the best troll in the world tommy fugan
shelby you are the freaking man
yeah bishop before would be possible to
you or the freaking man tommy
thank you so much oh you're gonna make
me cry
this man's gonna make me cry can you
believe that this this
this man is gonna make me cry okay
thank you so much i appreciate it tommy
you're the man no you're not going to
see tears today but maybe soon maybe
soon and we got another sub trill og
vog summing so my voice is
how is my voice different um is my voice
like i'm actually curious people have
been telling me that i can hear my own
voice
so i think i talk differently without
headphones but i wonder
like quantitatively what my voice what
the differences are
it's a little softer yeah well because
yeah because i hear my own voice so i'm
conscious of it
that's fair that's fair more calm okay
okay i'll try to i'll try to implement
that when i'm when i have my headphones
on
um oh dr alano throwing the challenge
out
interesting okay so white is better for
two reasons we're up a pawn and look at
black's position he's completely
undeveloped
and now we pile up on the on the weak
pawn on e5
part of the reason i saw bishop c3 is
what i noticed
knight f6 makes the move f6 impossible
so f6 would defend the e5 pawn as soon
as he plays knight f6 that gets the
alarm bells ringing
because this pawn is now basically
defenseless we know that the best way to
defend a pawn is with another pawn that
is impossible that means
this is by the way a dynamic factor
because
the knight on f6 would eventually be
likely to move
and then that would make f6 possible so
we want to exploit this asap
so knight takes f7 overloading if the
king takes then rook takes d7
and he resigned here as i explained he's
going to lose another pun
and that's going to be the game yeah so
you don't want to go crazy with static
versus dynamics but you you want to
use those to get a sense of like what
the priorities are
usually the priorities are going to be
to exploit the dynamic factors if you
can
and you shouldn't necessarily rush with
the static factors that's kind of you
know that's kind of um
the way you should think think of that
well why do i wear headphones it's just
like what i'm used to
and also i hear the move sounds and
stuff um it's kind of weird weird to not
wear headphones for me
okay um yeah there are several
books that um that talk about this which
are very very advanced
uh but but basically that's that okay so
any questions about the game would
bishop b4 have been good not sure what
you're asking
yeah i have to hear the move sounds
totally no same here as i'm here
so king b1 is is a general purpose move
that's very common when you castle and i
mean i guess the concrete reason is
we can envision a scenario where where
black gets c5 in
and the king could get easily caught in
the crossfire like i'm going to make
some random moves here
and we could easily envision a scenario
like this right where
okay now black has this pressure and we
accidentally go overnight we get
checkmated
and i can show you guys several examples
of a king on c1
actually getting super super in very big
very very
big trouble um and one of the most
beautiful applications of this i just
remembered a game that i've seen
years ago and let me show you guys that
game
i think an engine would play king b1 so
the accuracy on this game
is probably not very high but let me see
if the engine likes king b1 one sec
yeah not great it was like eighty
percent but the knee one was
yeah king b1 was was good mb1 was good
game b1 was a good move yeah engines do
like move like king b1
okay so let me just show one game before
we move on to the next one
if you guys just give me a second so as
you guys can see and we're going to face
this from black's perspective this is
the ghenion against planets
vaganyon um was an armenian
grandmaster one of the strongest players
in armenia in the 70s and 80s he's still
alive
alvin planets was from i think
yugoslavian
and unfortunately has a very very tragic
life story he
he suffer from a lot of mental issues
and later in life he
uh you know he kind of went off went off
the deep end but but he was an
incredibly strong attacking player one
of those guys that flies under the
surface most people haven't heard of him
but he played a lot of absolutely
brilliant games
um and this was one of them so what we
see here is that
um black is clearly attacking
but white is up a pawn and this knight
is in trouble
and so planets needs to find a way to
get to this king
and he finds in this position one of my
favorite combinations actually thank you
al kowalski
i'll tell you guys what move this game
combination starts with it's bishop f5
slovenian sorry
slovenian now he sacrifices the rook
and he does that in order to get the
queen away from the main
area of the board and now he starts
getting to the king with a beautiful
idea
um so what is the logical follow-up to
this
what's the logical follow-up to this
yeah 26 is correct you give the frontal
check to the king
now if the king goes to e2 then this is
going to be devastating the king has to
walk to f3
then you have a simple variation which
results in in one of several checkmates
so the ghanian goes to c1 he's like all
right big deal
okay you gave me a queen e6 jack king
gets even safer and now
guess what the reason i'm showing you
guys this game because the king is on c1
what planets notices king cannot escape
back to d2
so the king really has only one escape
path and that is to be one
so whatever he does he realizes it has
to be a night move if he moves his
knight away
then the king is sort of boxed in where
do you move the knight away knight a1
yeah
brilliant move knight a1 aiming for b3
this is a checkmate threat the gangnam
though is like whoa
whoa whoa my queen is going to have
something to say about that queen takes
b7
and if you give a check on b3 you belong
to the knight and here planets finds a
very very sexy idea
it's quite simple queen c7 check yeah
queen c7 check
queen takes c7 knight v3 checkmate i
always like these mates with a knight in
a bishop i think they're absolutely
stunning
and um there was nothing that mcganion
could have done about this if he didn't
get esquino
the attack would have just been
overwhelming that's a very very
beautiful idea
knight a1 queen b7 queen c7 now
made with two pieces vaganyan resigned
after queen c7 although it would have
been nice to let him
deliver that checkmate okay so king on
c1
you know if the king was on b1 it would
have a2
um i had a similar theme in one of my
games uh which my opponent could have
put on the board and failed to
yeah that is going in my tenor profile
exactly
if you a shortcut to no matches
just have that be your profile picture
okay that's that's pretty dirty stuff
right here
pretty dirty stuff
[Music]
you